it's been a pretty stressful time for
air passengers but just how bad have
cancellations been and where has fared
the worst well sky news has had access
to some exclusive data that gives us a
bit of an idea first have a look at this
this shows the proportion of flights
that have been cancelled out of all
major uk airports from january up until
last week so essentially the year so far
and look a bit of a leaderboard gatwick
at the top cancelled 3.2 percent of its
flights uh then glasgow bristol gatwick
actually cancelled about 10 times more
flights than stansted did at the bottom
there that was the uk's best performing
airport now we can break this data down
by airline as well and look what this
shows us is a bit of a global picture
lots of international airlines facing
similar challenges china at the top
clearly affected by covert issues and
rules but just cast your eye down i want
to draw your attention to british
airways uh in the middle there british
airways was the worst performing uk
airline in terms of cancellations now it
would say that's because it runs a much
more long-haul schedule it's much more
exposed to global factors but look it's
done much worse than ryanair right down
at the bottom one of the best performing
airlines in the world it says because it
didn't let go of so many staff during
the pandemic it's not facing the crises
that some other businesses are now how
did the uk fair internationally have a
look a similar picture again china
because of its covert rules america
canada very slow to open up but look the
uk was actually the worst performing
country out of all the major european
countries when it came to flight
cancellations so far this year now when
were most of these cancellations because
the context here really matters
essentially this shows the proportion of
cancellations compared to what was
scheduled going back all the way to the
start of the year you might think it's
been bad recently and it has look but
proportionally more flights were
actually cancelled in february march
time it won't have felt as bad because
fewer of us were trying to travel at
that time and you can see that more
clearly when we look at a bigger graph
that shows similar information at the
blue is the scheduled and the red is the
cancellation going back before the
pandemic look you might look at that red
and say that's not that bad but look
it's the schedule here is still fewer
quite scheduled than there were
pre-pandemic and that means you were
eight times more likely to have a flight
cancelled in june this year than you
were in june 2022. now it's important to
note this data only includes
cancellations within 48 hours of
departure so things could be much worse
many airports like gatwick and heathrow
are trying to take action to remove some
of the uncertainty but it's still a
worrying time for passengers